auch würde die ersten jetzt erstmal zu
ende und die leute die sich am ende noch
für die story interessieren können hier
einfach dranbleiben ist auf jeden fall
interessant das kann ich euch sagen hey
was geht ab von herzlich willkommen bei
einem video ja leute ich auch natürlich
geht es gut wir haben ja noch relativ
früh dafür dass ich schon videodreh ist
es 9 uhr
also habe ich schon echt länger
einsperren gefangen ich habe allerdings
leicht einen termin und ich wollte auf
jeden fall mal mit euch über ein
bestimmtes thema reden das ding ist nur
also ich will jetzt eigentlich nicht so
ein langweiliges lover video machen
wir haben auch relativ früh ich habe
auch noch nicht gefrühstückt und ich hab
gedacht hey was kannst du machen das ist
wie du vielleicht ein bisschen
interessanter wird weil das thema mir
echt auf dem herzen liegt das andere
thema war sicherlich auch cooles folgen
für mich selber freuen ich muss sagen
ich habe wirklich noch nie bei einem
fast food restaurant frühstückt und ich
bin gerade irgendwie auf die idee
gekommen
probier doch mal frühstück von macdonald
ich weiß gar nicht wie die menschen da
so ticken ob viele da frühstücken oder
nicht ich gehe aber davon aus dass es
nicht so ist deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht komm du holst jetzt erstmal
schön frühstück viele sachen wir
probieren die dann zusammen und reden
auch noch über das thema mit dem ich
gerne über mich redet heute ja ich hoffe
ihr seid lang wird schon interessant ich
hab hunger und lecker gefrühstückt habe
ich auch schon lange ich möchte
eigentlich der mensch ich frühstücke
eher selten und deswegen würde ich sagen
es geht es los ich habe übrigens diese
schuhe gekauft das war noch in rom ich
finde ich echt cool vor allem die waren
unter gesetz von 130 auf 50 euro da habe
ich wie man muss an dieser stelle auch
auf jeden fall war sagen schaut euch mal
das auto an
wie schön sauber steht das macht
wirklich so einen krassen unterschied ob
das gerecht ist oder nicht
vor allem weiß zu schwarz man sieht
wirklich direkt darauf so schimmer und
ist auf jeden fall ziemlich kalt gerade
ich weiß ich hab auch nur ein pullover
an
ich muss jetzt mal kurz ein bisschen
informieren ich habe da eben mal
nachgeschaut also wenn man hier mal
schaut wir haben ihr pancakes merkt aus
nietzsches mit werken mit schoko
das sieht auf jeden fall echt fett aus
diese ganzen sachen wo es so fleisch
drauf ist die musste ich unbedingt essen
da ich irgendwie mal uns so gar nicht
aber ebenfalls erstmal los und ich
musste mal die heizung einstellen wollen
ich bin echt schon so zu tun also bis
gleich
so leute ging ziemlich schnell warm egal
er richtig entspannt also sonst
irgendwie mein vater ich habe jetzt auch
echt hunger und ich habe gesehen einem
es gibt ein paar neue produkte zum
beispiel die pancakes die gab es vorher
gar nicht heute muss ich aufpassen und
ja da bin ich mal gespannt wie die
schmecken megawatt fertig pancakes recht
richtig gerne mag also wir sehen uns
sofort wieder
eigentlich wollte beim autofahren die
kamera halten aber ist das gar nicht
aber nicht nach
so leute irgendwie schien hat ihr das
hier ist irgendwie heute ziemlich viel
übungs verkehr also flug übungs verkehr
so als ich verstanden aber mit sagen wir
schnupfen einfach mal rein
danke für diese wenigen servierten wäre
gar nicht nötig gewesen
wir haben hier einmal da sie haben hier
t city breakfast alles ein croissant
dann haben wir hier bacon und das hier
ist denkbar dass kies und klassen müssen
jetzt pancakes sein ohr leute schaut
euch mal die pancakes an so leid ich
habe mir die pancakes war ein bisschen
größer vorgestellt aber ja
sieht ganz gut aus sie habe ich mir noch
so ein müsli geholt ich glaube das habe
ich schon mal gestern in irgendeinem
video ich weiß nicht mehr wo genau kann
auch sein das ist was anderes war aber
ich bin mal gespannt joghurt mit schoko
müsli
ich würde sagen die pentax haben zum
schluss aber das ist mit das ist mit
schokolade
das probiere ich mal am anfang ja wir
haben jetzt hier einen standort video
ich weiß nicht ob so was gibt aber habe
ich jetzt nicht eingeführt
also das ist schon alt trocken muss man
sagen dass die schokolade fall schon mal
gerade ihr fragt euch sicherlich ja alex
worüber willst du denn jetzt mit uns
reden was ist so wichtig das ding ist
ich weiß nicht ob es für viele von euch
so richtig ist für mich auf jeden fall
weiß das ganz projekt schon relativ
lange gibt und zwar geht es um meine
klamotten wald closing hieß es ja oder
heißt es doch immer noch die dass dieses
nur schauen um zu wissen wie das
schmeckt ich probiere sofort weiter
kämen ja ist mir auf jeden fall sehr
wichtig da wo man mit euch zu reden weil
eigentlich sollte am ersten dritten die
neue kollektion kommen es hat sich nicht
viel verändert und auch vieles
entwickelt man nichts ins positive
manche vielleicht auch ins negative
was haben wir hier jetzt das ist das mit
käse ich hoffe dass es besser dass man
ähnlich wie ein käse sein wird schlecker
die fünf eigentlich falsch wer zuerst
und darf ich zu reden ich so eklig aber
wir haben die ganze sache ungefähr vor
einem jahr gegründet die marke bei
closing kennen mittlerweile auch echt
schon viele menschen das muss man
ehrlich mal sagen auch instagram haben
wir da glaube ich 22.000 follower
das ding war von meiner seite aus ich
habe für so was halt eigentlich keine
zeit nebenbei auch noch klamotten zu
machen ich meine ich mache meine youtube
videos ich studiere und das ist schon
echt einen fulltime-job es sei denn ich
habe also wie erstmal frei und ich habe
das ganze damals mit zwei anderen leuten
angefangen die allerdings dann auch
gesagt haben wir müssen uns jetzt erst
mal was anderes konzentrieren wir haben
dafür jetzt nicht so viel zeit und dann
hat das einen dritter nochmal schulter
übernommen also er hat wirklich nur das
gemacht hier mir das jetzt glaube ich
auch noch mit bacon aber hier haben wir
auch noch das ist das denn an kosten
also kostenfrei ich auch richtig
ich hoffe dass frisch oder schmeckt
frisch
also interesse muss ich sagen es
schmeckt gar nicht schlecht nur es ist
ja klar mcdonagh kann jetzt nicht jeden
morgen frische croissants vom bäcker
wollen oder selber backen heißt thema
davon aus dass das tiefgekühlt schmeckt
man auch ein bisschen allerdings
trotzdem sehr gut für die verhältnisse
sage ich mal aber es schmeckt es halt
leider nicht so zu flach ich wenn man
das machen sagen kann wie einem
croissant halt wenn man es gerade frisch
vom bäcker aber ist voll okay kann ich
empfehlen ist lecker welchem viel
schokolade so hatte ich versuche also
voll den ausgleich zu finden zwischen
japan und essen eigentlich folgt
schilling auf jeden fall hat es dann
einen dritter übernommen
ich war zwar an sich noch mit dabei also
ich habe immer mal drüber geschaut oder
so und auch meine meinung zugesagt aber
habe halt nie wirklich mitgearbeitet
einfach weil ich keine zeit für hatte
das war ja ursprünglich auch so gedacht
dass ich erst mal mit mache das
vielleicht so ein bisschen populär zu
versuchen mache hat finde ich auch ganz
gut geklappt also ich kann da auf jeden
fall auch und ehrlich mit euch darüber
reden wir haben bestimmt insgesamt schon
über 1000 einzelne artikel verkauft was
auf jeden fall finde ich nicht schlecht
dass das sind tausend sachen 1000 leute
haben sich für diese sachen interessiert
ist für mich schon echt ein großer
erfolg gewesen und dafür auch auf jeden
fall danke an jeden
[Musik]
nur die sache ist diesen richtigen
durchbruch haben wir halt auch nicht
geschafft was aber auch echt schwer ist
es gibt so viele einzelne klamotten
marken eigene labels von ähnlichen
leuten die mir und jetzt sehe ich gerade
ich habe mich irgendwie folge klecker
also sowas tut ist echt schon schwer und
vor allem sowas hauptberuflich zu machen
ihr denkt euch jetzt wahrscheinlich was
ist denn daran viel arbeit an sich muss
man doch nur die klamotten einkaufen und
wieder verschicken
hey das gibt's ja gar nicht mehr wir
essen erst mal weiter glaube da hinten
brennt irgendwo etwas auch leute wir
essen jetzt erstmal zu ende und die
leute die sich auf eine noch für die
story interessieren kann er einfach
dranbleiben ist auf jeden fall
interessant das kann ich euch sagen
passiert so jetzt kommt bei hecken wollt
ich liebe denken also ich finde das ist
auf jeden fall das beste bis jetzt von
einheitlichen poliert habt wie käse
schokolade und käse das ist richtig
lecker class ist schon ein bisschen
kühler ich weiß wirklich wie lange ist
auch schon rum sagt aber man kann
trotzdem noch wie sie essen
jetzt geht's aber los hier
das ist schon wieder so klar alex tritt
einmal ein video die feuerwehr oder
krankenwagen fährt hier so selten lang
und jetzt kommen gleich zehn statt also
mac kann ich euch morgens wenn ihr jetzt
ungesund frühstück 9flats com zu den
pancakes hier ist auf jeden fall mit
teller drauf aber auch so eine art mohn
ist soße oder ich weiß es nicht
probieren kann man zucker ist ja auch
ein bisschen drauf und die schon gar
nicht richtig richtig gut
also die können auf jeden fall finde ich
mit so pancakes wenn man morgens gut
frühstücken geht mithalten ich weiß auch
die sind jetzt nicht super frisch aber
das schmeckt man nicht so leicht zum
abschluss als nachtisch das sieht
irgendwie voll westrich aus seht ihr das
wir tun das einfach mal hier rein also
zu den pancakes kann ich euch auf jeden
fall sagen probiert das mal wenn wir mal
frühstücken solltet ist echt richtig
lecker und das hier sieht sogar relativ
gesund auch ich weiß ist es
wahrscheinlich eher weniger aber wir
probieren mal
neue studie durch ich hoffe mal da ist
jetzt nichts schlimmeres passiert also
an dieser stelle viel glück euch dann
schnell also das schmeckt meiner meinung
nach richtig gut auch richtig lecker und
gar nicht mal so ungesund also im großen
und ganzen muss ich sagen ich bin
positiv überrascht schmeckt mir echt gut
kann man auf jeden fall machen aber ich
denke auch nicht so oft frei so gesund
ist das denkmal nicht also meinem
normalen frühstück würde ich das auf
keinen fall vorziehen aber den hier und
die pancakes kann ich am meisten im film
glaubt die anderen sachen gibt es auch
schon etwas länger
so und jetzt nachdem ich gut
gefrühstückt hat nur eine kleine sache
zu den klamotten also das was ich sagen
kann was ich auch selber hat viel
mitbekommen
sind halt leute mit denen man über
youtube oder sowas vielleicht leute die
sich mit der materie so gar nicht
auskennen eigentlich oder ich sage mal
mit diesem online geschäft auch unter
anderem freunde natürlich und viele
gehen halt davon aus so alex mit seinen
klamotten hey da machst du doch bestimmt
richtig fesch und was ich euch ehrlich
dazu sagen kann von dem was wir darüber
eingenommen haben habe ich wirklich
keinen einzigen cent bekommen also ich
hatte noch nie eine geldquelle durch die
klamotten klingt jetzt erst mal krass
aber es ist eigentlich verständlich hier
mal kurz angst und so leute also ich hab
damit wirklich keinen cent verdient das
ist auch gut zu erklären ich meine wenn
sie was jemand hauptberuflich macht dann
braucht dieser mensch natürlich auch
geld zum leben und das war dann immer so
ein plus minus geschäft es liegt immer
okay aber wie schon gesagt diesen
durchbruch haben wir halt auch noch
nicht geschafft das kann auch gut da
liegen weil ich am ende nicht mehr viel
werbung für gemacht habe ich war da
eigentlich so ein bisschen aus dem off
grade nicht zu 100 prozent hinter den
klamotten die jetzt eigentlich raus
kommen sollten
weswegen ich jetzt sagen muss dass wir
am ersten dritten keine neue kollektion
herausbringen mein ziel ist es aber in
zukunft mehr dafür zu machen
auch den style wieder so ein bisschen zu
ändern wäre das wollte ich euch mal kurz
zu erklären ich kann aber sagen es war
wirklich eine richtig richtig gute
entscheidung damals mitzumachen
wir haben auch viele coole sachen schon
erlebt wir waren es schon noch fort
ventura das wird auch darüber für
erzielt und so weiter also jetzt
komplett schlecht für mich war es nicht
macht sowas spaß und es ist dann halt an
sich kein richtiger job sondern mehr so
ein hobby das halt spaß bringen soll
einfach seine eigenen klamotten zu
machen also leute ich wollte damit nur
sagen am ersten dritten kommt keine neue
kollektion die kommt dann wahrscheinlich
zum ersten vierten dann allerdings war
es richtig cool ist wo ich auch komplett
hinter stehe und mit mache deswegen ich
blende euch hier mal kurz den instagram
account ein
ihr könnt ihr mal vorbeischauen und
folgen werden mega mega cool und ich
hoffe ihr freut euch dann auf die
kollektion ihrem ersten viertel online
kommt wichtig bei den sachen es mal
sie sind nicht zu teuer wir wollen das
nicht überteuert darstellen sodass bei
ziemlich vielen anderen shops der fall
ist
das wollte ich einmal gesagt haben und
ich hoffe das video hat euch gefallen
ist nicht zu viel von dem frühstück hier
sonst werdet ihr weg aber es schmeckt
lecker und gleich hab jetzt natürlich
nicht alle produkte probiert aber so die
hälfte und darf man das wo ich weiß das
schmeckt mir lasse dann 106 menschen zu
mir überhaupt wir sehen uns morgen
wieder morgen gibt's neues video hat
nein und ich habe jetzt mein tod